je
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de platon et on va parler en particulier
d'un fameux texte de platon qui
s'appelle l'allégorie de la caverne
je dis bien l'allégorie de la caverne et
non pas le mythe de la caverne comme on
l'entend parfois un mythe
c'est un récit fondateur d'une
civilisation or le texte de platon n'a
pas l'ambition de la prétention de
fondeyre une civilisation
l'allégorie de la caverne est un texte
qui a le mérite d'offrir un condensé un
résumé de la pensée de platon et si j'ai
voulu faire cette vidéo aujourd'hui
c'est précisément parce que je me suis
aperçu qu'on ne pouvait pas réellement
aborder la philosophie de platon sans se
confronter d'une manière ou d'une autre
à ce texte
alors quelques rappels sur des éléments
biographiques dont platon est un
philosophe grec du 5e et 4e siècle avant
jésus-christ c'était le disciple de
socrate un socrate qui n'a rien écrit
qui professait exclusivement un
enseignement oral est ce que l'on
connaît à propos de la philosophie de
socrate et bien on le connaît à travers
les textes de platon et notamment à
travers les dialogues de platon dans
lesquels il met en scène des personnages
qu'il a côtoyé parmi lesquels évidemment
socrates et dans ses textes platon nous
offre un aperçu des vues des pensées des
conceptions de socrate à travers des
échanges avec des interlocuteurs divers
c'est ce qui a d'ailleurs fait dire à
gilles deleuze que les personnages de
platon étaient des personnages
conceptuel davantage que des personnages
historiques puisque évidemment il est
impossible de vérifier si les dialogues
que platon a retranscrit ont
véritablement eu lieu il est donc
impossible de savoir si les textes de
platon traduisent la pensée réelle de
socrate ou bien s'ils traduisent en
réalité la pensée de platon lui-même
mais ça c'est un débat que je laisse aux
spécialistes rappelons simplement que
platon à exprimer sa pensée de la
manière la plus exhaustive
dans un livre qui s'appelle la
république dans lequel il fait une
description assez minutieuse de l'acadie
police la belle cité est l'allégorie de
la caverne fait précisément partie de
cette oeuvre
et dans cette allégorie platon exposé
sous une forme métaphorique sa
conception de l'accès à la connaissance
et on peut même dire que la caserne
constitue chez platon une représentation
de la condition humaine
alors avant d'entrer dans le détail de
l'analyse de cette allégorie de la
caverne devait être nécessaire de poser
quelques bases donc pour ce qu'il
souhaite vous pouvez vous reporter à ma
précédente vidéo sur platon intitulé la
vérité n'est pas de ce monde mais je
vais quand même prendre le temps de
rappeler quelques notions pour que vous
ayez des éléments sur lesquels vous
appuyer pour pouvoir suivre l'analyse et
l'interprétation qu'on va faire ensemble
de l'allégorie de la caverne
donc ce qui est fondamental de bien
comprendre chez platon c'est que pour
lui la réalité dans laquelle nous
évoluons c'est à dire la réalité
matérielle la réalité physique qui est
autour de nous pour platon cette réalité
là n'est pas la vraie réalité
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'elle
n'est pas la vraie réalité c'est un
petit peu étrange comme une manière de
dire les choses et bien pour le
comprendre il faut partir d'une
distinction fondamentale qu'opère platon
dans son oeuvre entre deux types de
réalité
deux types de réalité dont je précise
immédiatement que l'une est soumise à
l'autre il s'agit de la réalité sensible
et de la réalité intelligible alors
d'abord la réalité sensible qu'est ce
que ça veut dire la réalité sensible et
bien je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
la réalité dans laquelle nous évoluons
au quotidien c'est le monde physique
c'est-à-dire le monde qui se laissent
percevoir par nos sens c'est la réalité
matérielle qui est soumise aux
changements à l'évolution c'est à dire
tout simplement aux cycles temporel la
réalité que vous observez autour de vous
elle n'a pas été ce qu'elle ait de toute
éternité les arbres que vous allez voir
dans une forêt où même la montagne qui
va s'élever sous vos yeux
ça n'a pas toujours été là il y a des
centaines des milliers voire des
millions d'années l'arbre qui face à vos
n'existait pas la montagne qui était
face à vous n'existez pas parce que tout
ça est le fruit d'une évolution physique
ça est le fruit d'une transformation
perpétuelle du monde matériel
et donc le monde sensible le monde
matériel et physique
c'est le monde de la transformation
perpétuelle c'est le monde du devenir et
pour platon le devenir est toujours
synonyme de dégradation
je prendre un exemple très simple si
vous achetez un objet dans le commerce
qu'on importe lequel
cet objet avec le temps il va finir par
s'user va finir par s'user il va finir
par ne plus fonctionner il va peut-être
finir à la poubelle ou va finir au
recyclage
mais dans tous les cas cet objet va se
dégrader dans le temps il va se dégrader
jusqu'à quasiment disparaître même si
les atomes qui le composent ne
disparaissent pas il n'empêche que
l'objet en tant qu'objet lui va
disparaître va disparaître parce que la
matière se dégrade dans le temps la
matière ne possède pas un potentiel
d'existant civilité et de la même façon
le corps humain lui aussi se dégrade
avec le temps le corps vieillit le corps
s'use et il finit par se décomposer
jusqu'à disparaître
donc le corps humain le corps physique
est un exemple de ce processus
d'évolution inéluctable de tout être
matériel de tout corps physique qui
finit par se dégrader et s'anéantir dans
le temps donc le monde sensible c'est le
monde de la dégénérescence c'est le
monde de la dégradation et c'est
également le monde de l'imperfection
vous connaissez ce célèbre adage la
perfection n'est pas de ce monde
qu'est ce que ça veut dire bien ça veut
dire qu' aucun objet qui n'existe dans
notre monde physique
qu'il s'agisse d'un objet naturel ou
même d'un objet artificiel aucun objet
n'est parfait aucun objet n'est sans
défaut par exemple si vous tracez un
cercle au compas sur une feuille ce
cercle ne sera pas un cercle parfait
il y aura forcément des irrégularités
qui seront du peut-être à la texture à
la rugosité de la feuille ou tout
simplement à l'imprécision de votre
tracé mais le fait est que ce qu'on
appelle un cercle
c'est d'abord une réalité de l'esprit
c'est une réalité
idéal sens où elle relève de l'idée et
s'il est tout à fait envisageable de
concevoir un cercle parfait
le fait que ce cercle parfait existe
dans le monde
zik ça c'est totalement autre chose et
pour platon notre monde sensible et
marqué du sceau de l'imperfection
contrairement à l'esprit qui lui est
capable de concevoir des objets parfait
donc retenons ici que la réalité
sensible dont parle platon c'est à dire
notre monde physique notre monde
quotidien
c'est un monde qui est marqué par la
transformation perpétuelle c'est un
monde qui est marqué par l'imperfection
et il est vrai que si on y réfléchit
la réalité sensible elle se définit
d'abord par le mouvement dans notre
monde tout est en mouvement y compris
les atomes dans les objets inertes
si vous observez un livre posé devant
vous il est évident que ce livre ne va
pas se mouvoir mais n'empêche que les
atomes qui le constituent eux sont en
mouvement perpétuel et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que le livre existe parce que
des atomes qui ne se déplacerait plus ce
serait des atomes mort et dans ce cas là
l'objet lui-même n'existerait pas
donc tout corps physique est constituée
d'atomes de molécules de composants qui
sont eux mêmes en mouvement et c'est ça
qui leur confère une existence
matérielle
autrement dit le monde physique est par
définition le monde du mouvement et ça
ça rejoint la doctrine du mobilisme
d'héraclite le mobilisme c'est l'idée
que tout est mobile que tout est en
mouvement et c'est ce qui faisait dire à
héraclite que la seule vérité de notre
monde c'est la transformation
perpétuelle la seule vérité du monde
physique c'est l'impermanence c'est son
caractère mouvant son caractère évolutif
c'est ce dynamisme cosmique permanent
qui fait que tout ce qui existe
matériellement et soumis au temps et
soumis au devenir la réalité sensible le
monde physique c'est le monde du devenir
[Musique]
j'avais déjà donné cet exemple dans ma
vidéo sur berck sonne et le temps si
vous observez quelqu'un pendant
plusieurs heures
vous n'allez pas avoir cette personne en
train de vieillir
vous n'allez pas voir les marques de la
vieillesse apparaître à l'oeil nu sur
son visage et pourtant vous savez que le
processus du vieillissement est un
processus permanent
c'est quelque chose qui ne prend jamais
de pause et que donc nous sommes tous en
train de vieillir et chaque seconde qui
passe est une seconde qui nous rapproche
de la mort et c'est d'ailleurs ça qui
définit notre réalité physique ce
devenir qui fait que les choses ne sont
jamais identiques à elle même et que
tout ce qui a un début a une fin tout ce
qu'ils année sans ce à une mort est
finalement peut-être contre se poserait
pas autant de questions si la mort
n'existait pas si le temps n'existait
pas c'est à dire si les choses étaient
tout le temps identique à l
donc voilà ce qu'il en est du monde
physique et de ce mobilisme du monde
physique
sauf que pour platon le mouvement c'est
bien ce qui caractérise notre monde
le monde sensible perceptible par nos
sens mais ce monde selon platon n'est
pas le tout de la réalité
le monde sensible n'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga de tout ce qui est parce que
pour platon au delà de notre monde
il existe une autre réalité une réalité
invisible dit est imperceptible par mon
sens est pourtant une réalité qui est
supérieur à notre réalité sensible cette
réalité plate on l'appelle la réalité
intelligible c'est ce qu'il appelle
également le monde d essence ou des
idées ou encore des formes intelligible
1 toutes ces expressions chez platon
sont synonymes et pour platon les
essences elle possède un degré de
réalité supérieure à la réalité sensible
un degré de réalité supérieure ça veut
dire que pour platon les essences sont
quelque chose de plus réel que notre
monde sensible et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il est assez difficile pour nous de
concevoir parce qu'on a tendance à
associer la réalité à la matérialité
pour nous la réalité c'est ce qui est
palpable
c'est ce qui est perceptible c'est ce
qu'on peut toucher c'est ce qu'on peut
voir parce que pour nous réel ça
signifie matériel ça signifie qu'il ya
une existence concrète physique et donc
on a beaucoup de mal à envisager l'idée
d'une réalité non matériel
or et c'est ça qui va permettre de
comprendre toute la pensée de platon la
réalité intelligible c'est une réalité
supérieure à la réalité sensible
c'est une réalité qui à un degré d'être
supérieur à notre réalité matérielle
évidemment se pose la question mais que
sont ces essences que sont ses idées
qu'est ce que cette réalité intelligible
dont platon parler qui est imperceptible
à nos sens et c'est là évidemment que
les premières difficultés commencent à
apparaître
alors si je devais définir dans les
grandes lignes ce que platon appelle la
réalité intelligible je dirais que c'est
la structure immatériel de toute chose
et quand je dis de toute chose je veux
parler de toutes choses matérielles et
sensible
mais étant donné que c'est quelque chose
qui est très difficile à a expliqué
c'est très difficile de poser des mots
sur cette réalité intelligible je vais
recourir comme le fait souvent platon
d'ailleurs à une analogie
et pour ça je vais tout simplement vous
demander de vous représenter un jeu
vidéo
quand on joue à un jeu vidéo à quoi est
ce qu'on a à faire on a affaire à une
réalité virtuelle
c'est à dire que vous allez incarner un
personnage et ce personnage il va se
déplacer dans un univers donc vous
lorsque vous jouez à un jeu vidéo vous
êtes bien conscient que ce personnage il
n'existe pas réellement c'est un
personnage virtuel c'est un personnage
numérique digital ce n'est pas un être
de chair et d'os mais donc si ce
personnage que vous incarnez n'existe
pas réellement qu'il est son statut
quand je dis quel est son statut je veux
dire quelle est la nature de ce
personnage qu'est ce que c'est
réellement c'est pas une projection de
votre esprit puisque il est bien
perceptible par n'importe qui qui
regardera l'écran est bien ce personnage
et l'univers dans lequel il évolue
ce sont des émanations d'un langage
informatique
ce sont les émanations d'un code
c'est à dire que le jeu auquel vous
jouez c'est un système de programmation
informatique dont qui a été créée par
des développeurs et ce langage
informatique va créer l'illusion d'un
personnage et d'un univers illusion au
sens sensorielle
c'est à dire que le code informatique
vous n'allez pas le percevoir ce que
vous allez percevoir c'est l'émanation
visuel de ce code informatique est ce
que l'informatique d'une certaine
manière vous ne le connaissez pas vous
n'avez pas besoin de le connaître parce
que vous ce qui vous intéresse c'est de
jouer à votre jeu
donc vous n'avez pas besoin de savoir ce
qui se tient derrière l'animation
visuelle mais il n'empêche que pour
pouvoir jouer à ce jeu vidéo il faut
qu'il y ait eu d'abord un codage
informatique codage informatique dont le
jeu est une émanation
ce qui veut dire que si on adoptait un
point de vue platonicien on pourrait
dire que ce qui est plus réel que les
images qui défilent sur votre écran ce
sont les lignes de code informatique qui
se manifeste à travers les animations
qui sont sur l'écran
et d'ailleurs il suffirait de supprimer
toutes ses lignes de code pour que le
jeu vidéo n'existe plus ce qui prouve
bien qu'il ya une relation de dépendance
entre les animations et le code
informatique
mais la réalité profonde et structurelle
du jeu vidéo c'est le code
ce n'est pas l'animation puisque
l'animation l'a dit n'est que
l'émanation n'est que la manifestation
de ce code
et bien si vous avez compris cette
analogie vous avez compris 90% de la
métaphysique de platon c'est à dire de
sa distinction entre la réalité sensible
et la réalité intelligible alors une
fois n'est pas coutume pour cette vidéo
j'ai décidé de faire une lecture du
texte dont on va parler donc pour ce
qu'il soit vous pouvez suivre la
retranscription du texte sur l'écran
je précise que j'ai effectué quelques
coupures et quelques modifications du
texte originel pour le rendre plus
accessible
donc on y va ces partis représentent wa
de la façon que voici l'état de notre
nature relativement l'instruction et à
l'ignorance
figure-toi des hommes dans une demeure
souterraine en forme de cavernes ayant
sur toute sa largeur nantes réouverte à
la lumière ces hommes sont là depuis
leur enfance les jambes et le coup
enchaîné le sorte qu'ils ne peuvent
bouger ni voir ailleurs que devant eux
la chaîne les empêchant de tourner la
tête la lumière leur vient d'un feu
allumé sur une hauteur au loin derrière
eux entre le feu et les prisonniers
passent une route élevé imagine que le
long de cette route est construit un
petit mur pareil au poison que les
montreurs de marionnettes dresse de
vente et au dessus desquels ils font
voir leurs merveilles
figure toi maintenant le long de ce
petit mur des hommes portant des objets
de toutes sortes qui dépasse le mur et
des statuettes d'hommes et d'animaux en
pierre en bois et en toute espèce de
matière dans une telle situation il
n'aurait jamais vu autre chose d'eux
mêmes et de leurs voisins que les ombres
projetées par le feu sur la paroi de la
caverne qui leur fait face
si donc il pouvait s'entretenir ensemble
ne penses tu pas qu'il prendrait pour
des objets réels les ombres qu'il
verrait considère maintenant ce qui leur
arrivera naturellement sont les délivre
de leurs chaînes et qu'on l'ait guérisse
de leur ignorance on détache l'un de ces
prisonniers qu'on le force à tourner le
coup à marcher à lever les yeux vers la
lumière
en faisant tous ses mouvements il
souffrira et l'éblouissement l'empêchera
de distinguer ces objets dont tout à
l'heure il voyait les ombres que crois
tu donc qu'il répondra si quelqu'un
vient lui dire qu'il n'a vu jusqu alors
que devin fantôme mais qu'à présent plus
près de la réalité est tourné vers des
objets plus réel il voit plus juste et
si on le force à regarder la lumière
elle même ses yeux n'en sauront ils pas
blessé n'en furent at-il pas la vue pour
retourner aux choses qui peut regarder
et si maintenant on la rage de sa
caverne par force qu'on lui fasse gravir
la montée rude escarpé et qu'on ne lâche
pas avant de l'avoir traîné jusqu'à la
lumière du soleil ne souffrir at-il pas
vivement et ne se plaindre at il pas de
ces violences et lorsqu'il sera parvenu
à la lumière pourra-t-il les yeux tout
ébloui par son éclat distinguer une
seule des choses que maintenant nous
appelons vrai il aura besoin d'habitude
pour voir les objets de la région
supérieur d'abord ce seront les ombres
qui distinguera le plus facilement
puis les images d hommes et d autres
objets qui se reflète dans les eaux
ensuite les objets eux-mêmes
après cela il pourra affrontant la
clarté des astres et de la lune
contempler plus facilement pendant la
nuit les corps célestes et le ciel lui
même que pendant le jour le soleil et sa
lumière à la fin ce sera le soleil qui
pourra voir et contempler tel qu'il est
maintenant il faut appliquer point par
point cette image à ce que nous avons
dit plus haut
comparer le monde que nous découvrent la
vue aux séjours de la prison et la
lumière du fait qu'il est clair à la
puissance du soleil
quant à la montée dans la région
supérieur et à la contemplation de ces
objets situe la considère comme
l'ascension de l'âme vers le lieu
intelligible tu ne trompera pas sur ma
pensée dans le monde intelligible
l'idée du bien est perçu la dernière et
avec peine
mais on a peut percevoir sans conclure
qu'elle est la cause de tout ce qu'il ya
de grand et de beau en toute chose
qu'elle a dans le monde visible engendré
la lumière et le souverain de la lune
que dans le monde intelligible c'est
elle même qui est souveraine et dispense
la vérité et l'intelligence et qu'il
faut la voir pour se conduire avec
sagesse donc on va se livrer à une
petite herméneutique c'est à dire à une
interprétation de ce texte basé sur ce
qu'on connaît déjà de la métaphysique
platonicienne alors d'abord évidemment
la première chose qu'on va essayer
d'interpréter c'est cette métaphore de
la caverne elle-même une caverne qu'est
ce que c'est c'est un lieu sombre et
souterrains donc on va déjà retenir ces
deux idées et essayer de voir ce qu'ils
nous disent sur le plan symbolique
l'obscurité
ça renvoie évidemment à l'idée
d'ignorance l'obscurité c'est ce qui
s'oppose à la lumière et la lumière a
toujours été traditionnellement associée
à la connaissance à la vérité ne serait
ce que dans les expressions du langage
quotidien
quand on demande à quelqu'un de nous
éclairer sur une question quand on dit
que quelqu'un est une lumière la lumière
étant ce qui rend visible donc ici on
entendra visible à l'esprit la lumière
c'est évidemment le symbole de la
connaissance et ou de l'intelligence et
donc au contraire l'obscurité sera lié à
l'ignorance
on parle d'ailleurs de l'obscurantisme
qui est la tendance à se réfugier dans
sa propre ignorance donc la caverne
évoque l'ignorance et le fait que cette
caverne soit souterraines on peut
également interprété par rapport à la
hiérarchie des éléments qu'on retrouve
chez platon et dans l'antiquité en
général à savoir que l'élémentaire
c'est l'élément le plus bas c'est
l'élément considéré comme le plus vil et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui renvoie à
l'enfer dans le christianisme l'enfer
s'opposant au ciel du paradis le ciel
est en lui-même la sphère de l'esprit et
quand on dit qu'on prend de la hauteur
ou quand on dit qu'on s'élève bien
s'indigne à l'idée d'une supériorité de
l'élément céleste par rapport à
l'élément terrestre il ya donc dans le
choix de placer l'action dans une
caverne souterraine
l'idée qu'on se trouve au plus bas de la
hiérarchie de la connaissance
il faut ajouter à cela que dans la
conception de l'âme de platon la terre
représente la sphère des besoins
physiologiques
c'est à dire des besoins matériels de ce
qui nous rattache à notre condition
animale
c'est ce qui fait que dans la cité
platonicienne on trouve en bas de la
pyramide les artisans les paysans c'est
à dire les travailleurs de la terre le
travailleur du corps travailleurs
manuels qui sont considérés comme étant
à la fois indispensable indispensable à
la survie physiologique puisqu'en tant
qu'animaux nous avons des besoins
physiologiques qu'il est indispensable
de satisfaire mme mais de l'autre côté
de la pyramide au sommet on va trouver
les gouvernants qui sont les philosophes
c'est à dire ceux qui évoluent dans la
sphère céleste des idées de la pensée et
on a bien l'idée que c'est la pensée qui
doit gouverner le corps et c'est
l'esprit qui doit gouverner la matière
la matière étant associé à l'idée de
densité de lourdeur de pesanteur est
d'ailleurs lorsqu'on laisse tomber un
objet il est attiré vers le sol
il est attiré vers la terre c'est le
principe de la loi de gravitation qui
fait que le poids se fait plus fort
lorsqu'on est proche de la terre alors
que dans les airs on s'émancipe de la
pesanteur
donc pour résumer la caverne souterraine
c'est une représentation métaphorique de
l'ignorance initiale des hommes de
l'ignorance qui marquent notre condition
humaine à la naissance
il faut bien comprendre qu'il n'ya rien
de péjoratif là dedans on démarre tous
en bas de l'échelle on démarre tous au
niveau zéro et faire le choix de cette
allégorie de la caverne
c'est nous rappeler que en tant qu'êtres
humains nous ne sommes pas d'emblée dans
la connaissance ne sommes pas d'emblée
dans la sphère de l'esprit et de la
raison c'est quelque chose qui va
nécessiter un travail un processus
c'est ce processus qui va nous être
décrits dans la suite de la légaux
le deuxième élément qui va nous
intéresser c'est le fait que ces sommes
soient enchaîné autrement dit qu'ils
soient prisonniers
qu'est ce que ça veut dire être
enchaînés ça veut dire qu'ils n'ont pas
de faculté de mouvement et donc s'ils
n'ont pas la faculté de mouvement
ça signifie qu'ils n'ont pas la
possibilité de diversifier les objets de
leurs observations
ils n'ont pas la possibilité de tourner
la tête ils n'ont pas la possibilité de
se déplacer alors même que la
connaissance démarre avec l'observation
comparer des choses la connaissance
c'est se détacher de l'objet qui est
face à nous pour aller voir les autres
objets
c'est la comparaison c'est la mise en
relation c'est à dire que la
connaissance suppose le rapport à la
pluralité l'esprit il produit des
connaissances en dégageant des
généralités à partir d'une collection de
cas particuliers c'est ça qu'on appelle
la méthode de l'induction qu'on retrouve
notamment dans l'empirisme c'est à dire
que c'est à force d'avoir observé
d'avoir mis en comparaison les objets de
notre expérience qu'on peut commencer à
élaborer des lois et des généralités à
propos de ces objets donc pour platon
l'observation comparer ce serait la
deuxième marche de la connaissance et
cette deuxième marche de la connaissance
n'est pas accessible aux prisonniers de
la caverne qui sont face aux mêmes
objets qui n'ont pas la possibilité de
se déplacer et de diversifier les objets
de leur perception
autrement dit les prisonniers de la
caverne sont limitées à la première
marche de la connaissance ou premier
mode de connaissance qui est la
connaissance du matériel particulier
matériel particulier qu'on pourrait
opposer au matériel général si les
prisonniers avaient la capacité de
mouvement
il pourrait accéder au matériel général
vous pourrez accéder à cette seconde
marche de la connaissance
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'ils font la
distinction que faisait platon entre la
connaissance du matériel particulier
qu'il appelait l'opinion on pourrait
dire l'opinion confuse
c'est un peu l'opinion qu'on a quand on
a eu une seule expérience dans un
domaine ou avec un objet et qu'il
distingue du matériel général qu'il
appelle l'opinion droite et l'opinion
droite
c'est l'opinion qu'on forge et qu'on
construit à force d'expérience à force
de comparaison à force de confrontation
à la multitude
mais vous remarqué que dans les deux cas
on est dans la connaissance du matériel
c'est à dire que dans tous les cas notre
connaissance va porter sur des objets
physiques
or on sait et on l'a dit tout à l'heure
que pour platon le monde matériel le
monde sensible ne possède pas le degré
de réalité du monde intelligible et que
donc toutes les connaissances qu'on va
produire sur ce monde matériel non pas
la valeur non pas le degré d'efficience
des connaissances intelligible c'est à
dire des connaissances des choses de
l'esprit
dans les deux cas on se trouve donc dans
l'opinion la doxa puisque la réalité
matérielle est une réalité mouvante
réalité corruptibles et donc la
connaissance du monde matériel ne nous
permet pas encore d'accéder à une
connaissance véritable c'est à dire une
connaissance des essences une
connaissance des réalités intelligible
sachant que chez platon lorsqu'on passe
à la connaissance des réalités
intelligible on entre dans la science ce
qu'on appelle les pistes aimer la
science pour la distinguer de l'opinion
l'opinion étant l'ensemble des
connaissances à propos du monde matériel
on arrive à la troisième idée de cette
allégorie qui est le fait que ces sommes
sont enchaînées depuis leur enfance
alors ici qu'est ce qui apparaît
derrière cette expression depuis leur
enfance bien c'est tout simplement la
notion de conditionnement de
conditionnement dont j'ai parlé dans ma
précédente vidéo sur l'aliénation et
qu'on peut résumer par le fait que ces
hommes n'ont aucun autre référentiel que
celui de leur vie dans la caserne
ils n'ont pas d'autres référentiels
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas la
possibilité d'avoir un autre point de
vue sur le monde ils sont littéralement
prisonniers de leur point de vue
prisonniers de leur subjectivité
or on sait que la connaissance par
définition c'est la confrontation à
l'altérité
c'est le processus de 30 sujet ctive a
sion c'est à dire d'arrachement à sa
subjectivité d'arrachement à son point
de vue or on sait que l'enfance c'est le
moment privilégié de la formation de
l'esprit c'est le moment dans lequel la
construction cognitives et la plus
intense
on sait très bien que la période de
l'enfance est celle qui permet
l'apprentissage optimale donc pour
revenir sur la question du
conditionnement il est clair que le
meilleur moyen d'inscrire une conception
du monde dans un individu s'est dit
travailler depuis son enfance
parce que plus l'apprentissage a lieu
tôt et plus il est facile de le
systématiser donc le fait que ces
prisonniers soient enchaîné depuis
l'enfance montre à quel point leur
conscience et aliénée et montre à quel
point il va leur être difficile de
surpasser leur ignorance et d'accéder à
un niveau supérieur de connaissances
donc l'aliénation
c'est cette impossibilité constitutive
je dis bien constitutive d'envisager une
autre manière de voir le monde et donc
l'impossibilité radical de remettre en
cause ce que nous croyons connaître et
c'est en ce sens qu'on peut dire que les
prisonniers de la caverne sont à notre
image comme le dit socrates
ils sont à notre image parce que même
nous avons été conditionnés
nous avons été conditionnés par des
croyances par des habitudes par des
comportements qui parce que nous les
avons vécu de façon répétée pendant des
années depuis notre enfance ont fini par
s'intégrer à nous comme une seconde
nature
l'habitude est une seconde nature
et de la même façon qu'on ne peut pas
envisager ce dont on n'a jamais fait
l'expérience il paraît très difficile de
sortir de l'état d'ignorance
quand on est enfermé depuis notre
enfance et c'est là qu'on en arrive à
l'élément central de l'allégorie de la
caverne à savoir les ombres alors déjà
qu'est ce qu'une ombre une ombre c'est
la projection d'un objet qui est permise
par l'interception de la lumière donc ce
avec quoi je pense vous serez tous
d'accord c'est que une ombre n'est pas
un objet nombre c'est la trace d'un
objet c'est l'empreinte d'un objet hors
l'erreur des prisonniers qui est une
erreur tout à fait logique c'est de
considérer les ombres des objets comme
étant elle même des objets c'est de
considérer la trace de l'objet comme
étant elle même un objet une ombre n'est
pas un objet du seul fait qu'une ombre
n'a pas d'autonomie par rapport à son
objet l'ombre elle suit l'objet donc
elle a besoin de lui
l'objet c'est l'origine de l'ombre c'est
la source de l'ombre de la même façon
que les essences les réalités
intelligible sont à l'origine des objets
physiques et matérielles
donc lorsque les prisonniers observe les
ombres et les confonde avec des objets
réels ils font exactement comme nous
lorsque nous percevons des objets
physiques et que nous les prenons pour
la vraie réalité c'est à dire la réalité
des essences intelligible on pourra
d'ailleurs ajouté que l'ombre c'est une
zone d'obscurité l'obscurité étant une
métaphore de l'ignorance donc l'ombre
c'est une zone d'obscurité et par
ailleurs une ombre c'est également une
déformation de l'objet nombre elle a
grandi elle rétrécit elle allonge lé tir
mais dans tous les cas elles dénaturent
l'objet dont lé l'ombre l'ombre est
toujours une dénaturation de l'objet de
la même façon que pour platon le monde
sensible est une dénaturation une
falsification de la réalité intelligible
c'est ce qui fait dire à platon que le
monde sensible n'est que le monde des
apparences et qu'en tant que tel
l'apparence est toujours une déformation
une dénaturation de la réalité
intelligible une déformation d'ailleurs
vous noterez qui évolue car selon
l'endroit où va se trouver la lumière
selon la distance entre la lumière et
l'objet est bien l'ombre va prendre des
formes différentes de la même façon
qu'un objet physique va évoluer dans le
temps va prendre différentes formes ou
de la même façon également que
différents objets physiques se
rapportant à la même essence vont
également varier de l'un à l'autre
je disais tout à l'heure dans le monde
matériel il n'y a pas deux objets qu'ils
soient strictement identiques et donc si
on admet l'idée de platon que tout objet
matériel et la projection en mouvement
d'un objet intelligible la ce moment là
on comprendra cette idée qui n'existe
pas deux objets absolument similaire
deux objets qui soit la copie réel et
fidèle de la réalité intelligible dont
elles sont issues
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire encore sur les
ombres de huy que l'ombre c'est quelque
chose qui n'a que deux dimensions alors
que les objets des objets physiques ont
trois dimensions et ça ça a son
importance
l'ombre d'une sphère par exemple c'est
un disque l'ombre d'un cube c'est un
carré autrement dit qu'est ce qu'il se
passe elle se passe que l'ombre nous
fait perdre une dimension de l'objet
l'ombre nous fait perdre un élément
fondamental de la nature de l'objet et
ça c'est l'indicateur de la limitation
de notre champ de perception
j'ai dit à l'instant que les objets
réels avaient trois dimensions mais en
réalité c'est un abus de langage
parce qu'on ne peut pas affirmer que les
objets physiques ont trois dimensions
tout ce qu'on peut affirmer c'est que
nous nous les percevons en trois
dimensions mais nous les percevons en
trois dimensions parce que nous sommes
nous mêmes équipés d'un appareil
sensorielle qui nous fait percevoir le
monde en trois dimensions mais en
réalité nous est fondamentalement
impossible d'affirmer que le monde
lui-même comporte bien trois dimensions
parce qu'après tout il n'y a aucune
raison que notre esprit soit conforme et
à voir le monde tel qu'il est peut-être
sommes nous seulement conformer à voir
le monde tel que nous devons le voir
pour pouvoir nous y adapter
ce qui est très différent et pour ça on
a un bon exemple en géométrie à travers
l'exemple des hypercube qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un hypercube c'est un cube qui
possède une quatrième dimension et pour
modéliser visuellement ce qu'est cette
quatrième dimension
c'est très compliqué parce que comme
nous percevons tout en trois dimensions
il faut utiliser une astuce pour nous
faire comprendre l'existence de cette
quatrième dimension
et si on voulait représenter en trois
dimensions le déplacement d'un point sur
un objet qui en comportera 4 eh bien ça
apparaîtrait à nos yeux comme si le
point traverser une paroisse comme si le
point traverser les murs il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui s'intéressent aux
fantômes qui aurait cette capacité de
traverser les murs là peut-être que les
fantômes sont des êtres qui emprunte
tout simplement la quatrième dimension
mais tout ça pour dire que le discours
que vont produire les prisonniers sur
les ombres c'est une analogie du
discours que nous autres êtres humains
nous produisons sur la réalité sensible
et ce discours on ne peut pas être vrai
au sens entier du terme
tout simplement parce que c'est le point
de vue un individu qui est limité dans
son champ perception est donc le
discours qu'on va produire à partir
d'une perception limitée ne pourra pas
être vrai il sera lui-même limité
ça ne veut pas dire que ce discours sera
entièrement faux parce qu'il sera vrai
du point de vue de l'individu qui fait
l'observation mais il sera faux
vis-à-vis de la réalité de l'objet de
lui-même de l'objet qui se moquent
complètement de la limitation de notre
champ de perception et qui n'a pas
besoin de notre validation sensorielle
pour être ce qu'il est
donc si vous étiez un être en deux
dimensions et que je vous présentais un
cube vous verriez un carré et vous
auriez beau être absolument certain de
votre perception
il n'empêche que cette perception serait
fausse au regard de la réalité de
l'objet donc si la connaissance sur les
ombres est une fausse connaissance c'est
parce que la connaissance ne peut pas
être vrai si elle porte sur un objet que
l'on perçoit mal la connaissance ne peut
pas être vrai si on se trompe sur la
nature de l'objet que l'on cherche à
connaître
c'est en cela que la connaissance des
ombres est une fausse connaissance et
c'est pour ça que platon l'assimilent à
de l'ignorance
ce n'est pas une pure ignorance puisque
la pure ignorance n'existe pas et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que chez platon
la fosse connaissance est une étape
nécessaire dans le cheminement vers la
vraie connaissance de la même façon que
dans la dialectique de hegel le faux est
un moment du vrai l'opinion c'est le
fondement de la connaissance
on ne peut pas poser la pointe d'une
pyramide si on n'a pas la bo reposer ses
fondements
donc si on voulait faire un premier
bilan de cette allégorie de la caverne
on pourrait dire que les prisonniers
confondent les ombres avec les objets
réels confondent le simulacre avec la
réalité
les apparences sensible avec les
essences intelligible est ce qu'il faut
comprendre ici c'est que nous sommes
tous les prisonniers de cette caverne
nous parlons du monde qui apparaît à nos
yeux qui apparaît là nos sens et nous
croyons fort j'ai des connaissances sur
ce monde sans voir que nos prétendus
connaissances sont bâties sur du sable
puisque les objets de notre connaissance
ne sont que des ombres fnr ne sont que
des projections mobile qui en tant que
telle ne constitue pas la vraie réalité
la réalité des essences éternelle alors
on avance et on passe à l'étape suivante
qui est le moment de la libération des
prisonniers puisque platon va imaginer
ce qu'il se passerait si on les délivrer
de leurs chaînes alors délivrer le
prisonnier de ses chaînes ça suppose une
intervention extérieure
ça suppose un acte de libération
et ça ça veut dire quoi bien ça veut
dire que l'accès à la connaissance n'est
pas un processus spontanée n'est pas un
processus auto motor parce qu'il n'y a
pas de raison de sortir de l'ignorance
si notre ignorance ne se heurte pas à
une contradiction ne se heurte pas à un
élément étranger qui vient la remettre
en cause parce que le monde de
l'illusion
le monde de l'apparence peut être
parfaitement cohérent
on peut construire des systèmes
intellectuelle parfaitement cohérent
autour d'une situation fictive
on peut construire une connaissance
logique à partir de quelque chose de
faux d'où la nécessité d'une
intervention extérieure
et ce n'est pas nécessairement quelqu'un
qui doit intervenir
ça peut être un élément perturbateur un
élément qui vient contredire le système
qui va le remettre en cause
c'est par exemple les clercs de
l'étonnement bompard l'arrêt stop en
disant que la philosophie est la fille
de l'étonnement l'étonnement qui a la
même étymologie que le mot tonnerre
c'est la foudre qui s'abat sur nos
croyances s'abat sur ce que l'on croît
être vrai
on ça ça nous rappelle le principe de la
dialectique qui est qu'on ne peut avoir
de recul sur soi que grâce à la
médiation d'autrui et c'est vrai qu'on a
souvent besoin d'un point de vue
extérieur pour prendre du recul sur nous
mêmes nous sommes à la fois la personne
qui nous connaît le mieux puisque nous
sommes en colocation avec nous-mêmes 24
heures sur 24 365 jours par an mais nous
sommes également la personne qui nous
connaît le moins bien pourquoi eh bien
justement parce que l'habitude créé
l'inattention
on le voit à travers l'exemple des
accidents de la route qui se produisent
généralement sur des trajets qui nous
sont familiers
plus on est habitué à quelque chose et
moins on est habitués à y faire
attention donc de la même façon pour
remettre en cause nos croyances et pour
évoluer dans notre compréhension des
choses il est parfois nécessaire d'avoir
une intervention extérieure qui va nous
permettre de prendre du recul sur nous
mêmes
à ce moment là l'autre va représenter un
intermédiaire entre nous nous mêmes un
point relais entre nous et la
connaissance alors oui c'est souvent
désagréable parce que l'autre nous
bousculent dans nos certitudes et pour
peu qu'il soit sincère il va nous
confronter à des choses dont nous
détournons le regarde les choses que
nous n'avons pas envie de regarder en
face et auquel l'autre nous confronte de
manière impérative de manière
incontournable
et c'est ça qui fait qu'on va souvent
accordés de la valeur et l'importance
regardé personne qu'on aime parce qu'on
sait que leur point de vue à une valeur
le point de vue de l'autre nous
intéresse dans la mesure où il est une
autre porte d'entrée sur nous mêmes
pourtant très d'ailleurs dont nous
sommes pas forcément conscients
c'est aussi ça le rôle de l'autre dans
la dialectique de la connaissance
donc je disais que ce bousculement ce
dérangement nos certitudes avait quelque
chose de désagréable et cette idée elle
est suggérée par la notion
d'éblouissement dans l'allégorie
l'éblouissement du prisonnier par la
lumière du soleil
or qu'est-ce que l'éblouissement c'est
un choc c'est une violence
c'est un éclat qui est trop brutal pour
pouvoir être supportés et ça aussi c'est
une assez bonne métaphore des effets de
la vérité lorsque l'on se confronte à
elles à savoir que la vérité nous
éblouit
elle nous éblouit non pas parce qu'elle
est la vérité mais parce que nos yeux
n'y sont pas habitués
c'est pas la vérité qui nous éblouit
c'est la première confrontation avait
quelque chose de nouveau parce qu'une
vérité admise est digérée perd son
caractère brutal
mais si au début la confrontation à la
lumière de la vérité est quelque chose
de désagréable platon nous dit que nos
yeux s'habituent à la vérité et pour ça
il nous faut du temps
ce que vous me dire ici platon c'est le
caractère progressif de l'accès à la
vérité parce que l'accès à la vérité ne
se fait pas par un saut par un bon on
atterrit pas dans la vérité on ne passe
pas de l'ignorance à la vérité sans
étape intermédiaire c'est pour ça que le
texte ne dit que l'ancien prisonnier
arrivera d'abord à percevoir les ombres
puis le reflet des choses dans l'eau
encore on retrouve cette idée de
hiérarchie des éléments puisque l'eau se
situe au dessus de l'élémentaire et
ensuite ce sont les objets eux-mêmes
qu'on arrive à percevoir donc platon
nous décrit le processus de la
connaissance comme un processus
d'ascension comme un processus
d'élévation de l'âme vers l'intelligible
et au terme de ce processus il nous est
possible de contempler directement les
objets de les regarder en face en
quelque sorte c'est ce que platon
appelle la contemplation des essences et
donc lorsqu'on accède à ce degré de
connaissance cette contemplation des
essences à ce moment là on est sorti du
domaine de l'opinion c'est à dire de la
connaissance de la réalité sensible et
on est entré dans le domaine de la
science c'est à dire la connaissance des
réalités intelligible alors pour
illustrer ce passager cette ascension de
l'âme vers l'intelligible je vais
prendre un exemple qui est l'exemple de
la beauté ce que nous dit platon c'est
que pour accéder à l'idée de beauté
c'est à dire au bo en soit au beau comme
essence comme forme intelligible
il est d'abord nécessaire de respecter
des états la première étape c'est
l'étape de la reconnaissance d'une belle
choses belles choses ou d'une belle
personne c'est-à-dire souvenez-vous ce
qu'on a dit tout à l'heure la perception
d'un objet matériel particulier donc ça
c'est ce qui se produit quand vous
percevez un bel objet ou quand vous
rencontrez une belle personne vous êtes
face à un cas matériel et particuliers
de beauté et puis ensuite le degré
supérieur c'est la reconnaissance des
belles choses ou des belles personnes
c'est quand vous êtes capables
le de généraliser la beauté à toutes les
choses ou à toutes les personnes qui
possèdent cette beauté
à ce moment là on entre dans le deuxième
niveau de connaissance qui est la
connaissance du matériel général mais
sauf que dans ces deux cas on est
toujours dans la connaissance matériel
c'est à dire on est toujours dans ce que
platon appelle l'opinion la doxa et
c'est ça qui nécessitent d'accéder à un
troisième niveau de connaissance qui est
la connaissance du bo en soi du beau
comme idée et qu'est ce que c'est que le
bo en soi eh bien c'est la beauté qui se
manifeste dans les belles choses c'est à
dire que vous n'avez plus besoin de
contempler des belles choses pour
reconnaître la beauté pour savoir ce
qu'est la beauté c'est ce qui fait que
vous allez être capable de percevoir la
beauté dans tout ce qui existe et même
au delà de tout ce qui existe au delà de
tout ce qui a une forme matérielle
saissac platon appel l'idée du bo où la
beauté en soi et c'est ça pour lui qui
vient couronner le processus
d'abstraction c'est à dire le processus
d'ascension de l'âme vers l'esprit
l'élévation vers la connaissance
immatériel
c'est à dire l'accès aux essences
parce que chez platon la connaissance
est tojours connaissance de l'immatériel
je vais reprendre l'exemple du cercle le
cercle avant d'être quelque chose que
vous allez percevoir par vos sens
c'est d'abord une réalité intelligible
c'est d'abord une idée un concept le
cercle c'est une réalité spirituelle qui
peut à l'occasion s'incarner dans le
monde matériel bien de la même façon
avec la notion de beauté vous n'avez pas
besoin de voir lit même d'imaginer
quelque chose ou quelqu'un de beau pour
avoir la connaissance de ce qu'est la
beauté
la beauté devient alors une réalité
spirituelle une réalité immatériel une
réalité intelligible
et donc je disais que la connaissance
chez platon et toujours connaissance de
l'immatériel tout simplement parce que
la connaissance des choses matérielles
et soumise aux variations des choses
matérielles
la connaissance des choses matérielles
et dépendante des évolutions des
transformations des choses matérielles
ce qui veut dire qu'une connaissance que
vous aurez sur un objet matériel ne sera
valable que le temps où cette chose
matérielle restera identique à elle même
que le temps où cette chose ne changera
pas or étant donné que tout ce qui est
dans le monde matériel évolue
inéluctablement la connaissance que vous
aurez des choses matérielles ne sera
plus valable à partir du moment où cette
chose ne sera plus ce qu'elle était
alors que les essences et forme
intelligible elle elles sont intactes de
toute variation elles sont fixes elles
sont immuables et la tâche de l'apprenti
philosophe et dial consiste justement à
reconnaître dans toute chose les sens
qui l'animent
par exemple reconnaître la beauté dans
tout ce qui contient de la beauté
il se trouve que chez platon il existe
une essence suprême naissance au delà
des essences cette essence au delà des
essences c'est le bien le bien en soi
l'idée du bien
dans l'allégorie de la caverne le bien
en soi est représenté par le soleil et
c'est amusant parce que le soleil c'est
à la fois ce qui fait exister le monde
par sa chaleur et ce qui le rend
reconnaissable par sa lumière le feu
c'est à la fois la condition de notre
conservation la condition la vie mais
aussi la condition de la connaissance
on va dire la condition de notre
conscience
or
si on fait cette addition la vie plus la
conscience
bien on atteint là le bien suprême le
bien le plus haut auquel humains
puissent accéder
la vie est un don et la conscience de la
vie c'est la conscience du don qui nous
est fait
le don implique toujours une
responsabilité minimale qui est de
prendre soin de ce dont nous sommes
effectivement responsable de ce que nous
faisons de la vie
chez platon les sens ultime c'est le
bien qu'ils s'identifient avec l'un
l'unité
l'un c'est ce qui trône au dessus du
monde de la multitude
ce qui veut dire que nous sommes tous
des enfants de l'unité en venant au
monde
sommes plongés dans la multitude nous
sommes plongés dans le chaos
parés de l'unité originel
séparée de l'éternité mais une part de
nous qu'on tient toujours cette éternité
c'est notre âme en tram qui connaît la
vérité notre âme qui se souvient de
l'unité dont elle provient
et qui aspire à la rejoindre
pour continuer à s'accomplir le cycle du
devenir
je vous remercie
[Musique]